ja hier in miami findet in kürze der
super bowl statt das finale der national
football league zwischen den kansas city
chiefs und den san francisco dort hinein
und es wird da sind sich alle einig ein
mega spektakel werden auch in diesem
jahr mit ungefähr 800 millionen
zuschauern weltweit das besondere in
diesem jahr ist dass das spiel so
ausgeglichen werden wird wie schon lange
nicht mehr
beide mannschaften sind ähnlich stark
sind ähnlich erfolgreich durch die
saison gekommen spielen aber völlig
unterschiedlich die san francisco fort
hinein als bei denen auch der deutsche
marken georgia spielt kommen er über
ihre kompakte defensive
die kansas city chiefs über ihre
herausragende offensive angeführt vom
neuen möglicherweise shooting-star der
nfl patrick mayer holmes die stimmung
hier in der stadt zwischen palmen
yachten kreuzfahrtschiffen ist auf jeden
fall berechtigt sind zahlreiche fans aus
dem gesamten vereinigten staaten
angereist tausende zehntausende an der
zahl und sie alle freuen sich auf das
spiel das in der nacht zum montag
deutscher zeit stattfinden wird
man darf gespannt sein wie das spiel
ausgehen wird letztlich entscheiden
wahrscheinlich kleinigkeiten aber die
mannschaften so viel steht fest werden
alles daran setzen das erwartete
spektakel auch auf dem rasen umzusetzen